well Labor's brexit position has in the
words of the shadow Chancellor John
McDonnell evolved and the party's stance
on a second brexit referendum that it's
not currently their position has left
some thinking that they've deliberately
left the odd door open while today the
London Mayor Sadiq Khan has thrown his
weight behind a second vote so joining
us now is the shadow international trade
secretary Barry Gardner thank you for
being with us this morning it feels like
we should start off with the comments by
the London man saying that he would like
to see a second referendum do you agree
with them look John's right we've said
that we haven't ruled anything off the
table but I thought what Colin Jones
said earlier and your program is very
sensible and actually to have a second
referendum would be to throw this
government a lifeline here we have a
prime minister who is facing going to
Parliament with whatever she eventually
manages to conclude with the European
Union and find that it is not possible
to get it through the British Parliament
well in those circumstances I think the
right thing to do is to say if this
government cannot do what it is supposed
to and govern then we need actually to
change the government calling for a
second referendum is is is really giving
her a lifeline because then she can say
oh well and if I can't get it through
Parliament and I'll go back to the
people but what does she go back to the
people on because this is not just a
two-way question you know is it whatever
she's managed to negotiate or No Deal
and we crash out or is it whatever she's
managed to negotiate and we stay in the
European Union so it's not clear whoever
writes the question manipulates the
answer that they want to get and of
course it will be this government that
is writing the question the first
referendum cause real division in our
society I think the challenge now is
actually to try and heal society it's to
take note of what was originally said by
the British people in that referendum
but to do so in such a way that is
protecting jobs and our economy and
growth because many of the things and
carbon was absolutely right many of the
things that are now being talked of by
the government has
part of a possible deal we're never
taught you spoke there about the
divisions of the brexit vote created and
you said previously that a second
referendum could actually lead to civil
disobedience I mean what do you mean by
civil disobedience no what does that
mean you know what genuinely civil
disobedience is is four-term you know
people have campaigned on the streets
they go marching on the streets and the
suffragettes engaged in civil
disobedience and the people are green
common engaged in civil this would be so
far not know look let's let's try and
address the fundamental issue here okay
because the fundamental issue is do we
want a society that is united and says
ok I haven't got everything that I want
we've got we've got two groups in
society and one that are ardent ly
wanting to leave everything to do with
the European Union
whether it's customs union work whether
whether it's single market whether it's
euro sat whether it's you know the
European emissions trading scheme they
they just want out another group that
say no what we want is we're prepared to
leave the European Union but actually we
you know we don't want to leave all
those other things which give real
benefits to our societies bring back
bringing back what would come home
nights the country not increased the
division can I just bring you back to
what you think would happen if there was
a second referendum what do you think
would happen do you think we'd see
people on the streets do you think we'd
see movements like well you mentioned
the suffragettes like that kind of
passionate sometimes violent glue
painting right so what do you think I
think that people are deeply deeply
upset on both sides and what we have to
try and do is to heal that division not
perpetuated the second referendum should
be taken off the table of them know what
sounds like you do know for that look
the reason the reason that we have not
ruled anything out is because nobody
knows what's going to happen over the
next few weeks but that is an indictment
of this government this government went
into those negotiations without a proper
mandate they accepted the the timetable
that was given to
by the Commission on day one they
decided that they would first of all
agree all the things that Europe wanted
without actually and and then move on to
the thing that we wanted which was a new
trade relationship with them
that was insane this government has
messed up the deal for the past two
years what we need to try and do now is
chart a way through the difficulty that
their incompetence has caused that's
what we in the Labour Party are doing
that's why we're not we're not saying
it's definitely got to be there so it's
definitely got to be that we're saying
we have to be flexible because we have
to respond to the situation let's talk
about that flexibility we mentioned the
Carmen Jones interview I thought it was
very interesting that he said that in
his view checkers was a step in the
right direction even though labor want
to go further was a step in the right
direction and Emily Thornberry however
has effectively said that whatever deal
with trees may comes back with labor is
not going to support it I mean is that
really no Emily didn't say she said I
can't see them she said she looked at
text and that a workable deal was just
not going to happen I do man that sounds
like it's not gonna pay for anything
that hits Emily Emily in it quite
properly expressed her deep skepticism
as to whether this government was going
to produce a deal that was acceptable I
think most people in the country think
that we are heading for a situation in
which whatever is eventually concluded
with the European Union is going to be
unacceptable to a blocking minority in
Pilon but you think that you could see a
solution where labor would support a
deal if you thought it was acceptable
not your task if it meets the six tests
that we've laid down if it is a if it's
a deal that is clearly going to be
positive both of the security of the
country because remember this is not
simply about trade and economics it's
also about our future security
relationship with the European Union
it's a much wider engagement that we
have that the gump
and some of those who want No Deal are
seeking to wrench us away for now I'm a
little bit of mischief in the newspaper
you always do this to me
what happen to that nice man that was
here when you were away
I'm not sure how you take that now
there's a story in The Sunday Times to
give me on being mischievous claiming
that allies of John McDonnell are
sounding people out about jeremy
corbyn's future do you think that john
mcdonald would be a good leader that
john has done an extraordinary job this
week and he has gone out there talking
to the public
talking to the British people about how
ordinary people can get a fair share of
the wealth that they create he's talked
about rights for gig economy workers
he's talked about the way in which those
workers in bigger companies over 250
employees can get shares in those
companies so they feel a sense of
ownership and the productivity and the
profits of those companies and he's
talked about her financial transaction
tax and which would actually improve our
financial services by stopping the churn
and they and the speculation and but
bring five billion into the economy
these are the things that the Labour
Party has been focused on this week
about how to make ordinary people in
this country better off that's what we
want to see but look everybody in the
shadow cabinet is absolutely United
around Jeremy's leadership jeremy has
been an extraordinary leader at a time
when when people thought it was not
possible for the labour party to come
back he has done that and we're united
around him for one reason because the
Labour Party is the best means of
improving the social conditions for
people in this country making it a fair
and equal and a better place now I'm I
would love to talk to you more about
trade but I know that labor very keen to
for us to get this final question in
because it's a story that they're
pushing this weekend about the high
streets and about the state of the high
streets and I do want to talk about it
because in Bridgend it came up again and
again in Wales that people were pretty
devastated about the sight of shops
closing down in the state of the Hydra
so what are you planning to do and a
hundred thousand jobs have gone in reach
in the past three years that that's
quite extraordinary if you think of that
as a proportion of people in employment
in our country they've disappeared off
the high street and so what we're saying
is that we want to have a register of
the landlords of those premises so that
we can easily replace companies going
back in there rather than seeing them
left vacant and also do sorry is that my
toilet thing I think that's pretty much
your time fotis we did get there I I
hate doing this to you but and thank you
very much for being with us as a Barry
gardener thank you